de réunion
en seulement
nos intervenants que je vais présenter
dans mon petit texte d'introduction et
mes collègues qui sont en ligne pour
suivre en visio
ces interventions merci aux collègues
présents Michel merci Pierre Martine
la délégation aux entreprises évidemment
très heureuse de vous accueillir ce
matin
pour échanger sur le partage de la
valeur sujet qui
commence à monter et qui devient
vraiment important et qui nous intéresse
en particulier pour les petites et
moyennes entreprises puisque c'est la
cible de des travaux de la délégation
aux entreprises
alors que le contexte économique
d'inflation est source d'inquiétudes
pour le pouvoir d'achat des Français
mais que versement de dividendes
d'actionnariat atteint dans le même
temps des niveaux records l'enjeu lui
partage des profits retrouvent
l'actualité certaine la dimension de
justice sociale est importante puisque
s'il partage de la valeur constitue un
complément de salaire seul 20% des
salariés des entreprises de moins de 50
salariés en bénéficient aujourd'hui
contre 89% dans les entreprises de plus
de 1000 salariés
d'accord national interprofessionnelle
sur le partage de la valeur conclut le
10 février 2023 signé par la majorité
des organisations syndicales
représentatives vise notamment à
généraliser à compter du 1er janvier
2025 des dispositifs d'intéressement de
participation ou de prime de partage de
la valeur à toutes les entreprises de
plus de 11 employés et à développer
l'actionnariat salarié pour transposer
cette amie un projet de loi relatif au
partage de la valeur que la première
ministre a présenté comme fidèle à
l'accord a été adopté ce mercredi 24 mai
donc on est vraiment dans l'actualité
en conseil des ministres elle sera
bientôt examiné par le Parlement
lorsqu'il sera juridiquement stabilisé
afin d'anticiper ce débat la commission
des finances de l'Assemblée nationale a
publié en avril dernier un rapport
d'information sur l'évaluation des
outils fiscaux et sociaux de partage de
la valeur dans l'entreprise ce dernier
souligne est sujet qui pourront être
source de débat au Parlement par exemple
la définition de résultat exceptionnel
et les effets redistributifs dans la
chaîne de valeur avec la table ronde de
ce matin notre délégation aux
entreprises en temps aborder l'examen de
ce texte avec une vision éclairée par
les témoignages de nos intervenants
l'approche économique et l'analyse
concrète de l'impact de l'accord sur les
plus petites entreprises pour mieux
comprendre les espoirs et difficultés
que sa mise en oeuvre suscite au sein
des PME seront précieuses
je rappelle que depuis désormais plus de
8 ans la délégation d'entreprise a pour
mission de recenser les obstacles au
développement des entreprises et de
proposer des mesures visant à simplifier
les normes applicables à l'activité
économique en vue d'encourager la
croissance et l'emploi dans les
territoires TPE PME ETI sont au cœur de
nos préoccupations et nous nous
efforçons toujours d'appréhender
l'impact des grandes réformes pour les
plus petites entreprises
vont intervenir ce matin pour cette
table ronde tout d'abord madame Sophie
piton économiste à la Banque
d'Angleterre et au centre de
macroéconomie de Londres là vous pourrez
nous aider à définir les termes du débat
situé la portée de la ni dans une
perspective macroéconomique
puis madame Stéphanie posa
vice-présidente délégué de la CPME qui
interviendra en visioconférence madame
vous pourrez préciser ce que
concrètement les nouvelles règles vont
changer dans les PME sont-elles
suffisamment préparées et quels seront
les éventuels difficultés rencontrées
enfin Monsieur François Péret
ambassadeur à l'intéressement et à la
participation ce matin par ailleurs
directeur général de tract d'emploi
vous pourrez nous éclairer évidemment en
évoquant la mission que le gouvernement
vous a confié depuis 2019 et un
rappelant le contexte dans lequel la
henné a été conclu en précisant les
enjeux là aussi pour les PME j'essaierai
donc tout d'abord la parole dans l'ordre
présentation si vous le voulez pour un
propos liminaire durant 7 minutes chacun
puis avec mes collègues pourront poser
évidemment des questions
utilisez donc bien vos micros puisque il
y a une retransmission pour nos
collègues qui sont sur le réseau et
également pour la captation audiovisuel
et la retranscription de nos échanges
qui sont fait en direct je vous remercie
et madame je vous laisse la parole
merci beaucoup j'espère que tout le
monde m'entend bien donc avant de
démarrer je souhaiterais juste donc
j'avais des slides je sais pas si on va
les afficher mais bon sinon c'est pas
c'est pas très grave mais avant de
démarrer je souhaitais juste préciser
que cette présentation est pas
représentative des Opinions de la Banque
d'Angleterre voilà mais bien personnelle
donc je vais introduire ce tableau ronde
en donnant un point de vue
macroéconomique donc un point de vue
d'ensemble du partage de la valeur
ajoutée pour ensuite discuter un peu
plus précisément les les mesures
proposées par cet accord en particulier
celle qui concerne donc les petits et
moyennes entreprises puisque c'est le
point d'intérêt de cette délégation donc
je vais pas discuter ces dispositifs de
manière détaillée et concrète je
laisserai les autres intervenants de
cette table ronde certains m'ont
beaucoup plus compétent que moi pour
pour discuter de ces mesures
donc avant de discuter du partage de la
valeur ajoutée il est donc important de
comprendre sa mesure donc je vais
brièvement rappeler les concepts en jeu
et donc qu'est-ce que la valeur ajoutée
la valeur ajoutée c'est la richesse
produite par l'entreprise donc son
chiffre d'affaires auquel on déduit le
coût des entrants acheter un tiers ce
qu'on appelle en comptabilité nationale
donc la consommation intermédiaire donc
cette valeur ajoutée ensuite ce partage
à la fois en rémunération du travail et
en bénéfice donc je fais abstraction
abstraction ici de des impôts et des
subventions pour la production mais il
est bien important de comprendre que les
rémunérations de travail ici incluent à
la fois les salaires et les sommes
versées au titre de la participation de
l'intéressement ainsi que les
cotisations sociales
donc les bénéfices sur ce qu'on appelle
en comptabilité nationale l'excédent
brut d'exploitation donc le Be et ce qui
peut être utilisé pour être réinvesti
dans de nouvelles machines enfin
l'investissement ou être utilisé pour
payer les actionnaires donc la
distribution des dividendes donc quand
on parle de la part du revenu des
entreprises qui revient au travail le
plus souvent on s'intéresse donc à la
part de l'ensemble des rémunérations du
travail dans la valeur ajoutée et c'est
cette part qui nous permet de suivre
l'évolution de salaire relativement au
bénéfice des entreprises
donc je précise que c'est définition
sont un peu différentes si on
s'intéresse à la comptabilité nationale
et qu'on regarde à l'ensemble de
l'économie ou si on s'intéresse à la
comptabilité d'entreprise ou les masse
salariale n'inclus pas l'intéressement
et la participation et où le bénéfice
notamment le bénéfice utilisé pour le
calcul de la participation est un
concept un petit peu différent de cette
excédent brut d'exploitation le BE voilà
donc c'est le slide de définition merci
et qui utilise une définition un peu
différente vous avez parlé avec tous les
débats sur quelle définition des
bénéfices autant de l'entreprise il faut
utiliser pour le calcul de la
participation mais donc là je vais
donner une vue d'ensemble en utilisant
vraiment cette cette approche de
comptabilité nationale donc si on
regarde sur le slat suivant donc si on
regarde
donc le troisième slide si on regarde
l'évolution de la part de l'ensemble des
rémunérations dans la valeur ajoutée
donc c'est le graphique de droite ici on
observe une stabilité sur le long terme
autour de 70%
avec quelques fluctuations et notamment
une augmentation autour du choc
pétrolier dans les années 70 des deux
chocs pétroliers dans les années 70
alors que les salaires étaient indexés
sur l'inflation puis une correction liée
à la baisse du pouvoir de négociations
de salariés moi aussi
l'intensification de l'utilisation de la
robotisation l'automatisation dans les
années 80 mais cette part est
aujourd'hui globalement au même niveau
que dans les années 50 donc toujours
autour de 70%
. cela masque néanmoins des évolutions
importantes dans le mode de gouvernance
des entreprises ce que en France Michel
Aglietta décrit comme le passage d'un
capitalisme contractuel dont la
négociation salariale était vraiment un
élément important au cœur de cette forme
de capitalisme à un capitalisme ce qu'il
appelle financière dans le début des
années 80 PLUS entrée sur la valeur
actionnariale
donc l'intéressement et la participation
et je pense que c'est un Allemand que
que cet accord rappelle en introduction
je pense que c'est important de d'avoir
ça en tête l'intéressement et la
participation était introduit dans les
années 60 comme outil de négociation
salariale dans ce capitalisme
contractuel
voilà donc en termes de comparaison je
restais sur le slide d'avant donc en
termes sur comparaison internationale
donc les évolutions à long terme de la
part des rémunérations du travail dans
la valeur ajoutée sont à peu près
similaires dans la majorité des pays
européens mais différentes aux
États-Unis où on voit une baisse
importante de la part du travail depuis
le début des années 2000 et donc il faut
c'est important aussi de comprendre que
cette baisse aux États-Unis reflète le
poids croissant d'un petit nombre de
très grandes entreprises dans lesquelles
la part des rémunérations du travail
dans la valeur ajoutée est très basse
donc un effet de ce qu'on appelle un
comique un effet de composition
donc une évolution stable à long terme
mais du coup dans ce slide suivant ici
qu'est-ce qu'on regarde la contribution
de la participation et de
l'intéressement
dans cette évolution de la part de
l'ensemble des rémunérations du travail
dans la valeur ajoutée donc seule la
participation est un dispositif
obligatoire dans les entreprises de plus
de 50 salariés elle redistribue une
partie des bénéfices de l'entreprise aux
salariés et l'investissement
l'intéressement quant à lui donc
rémunère latin d'objectifs collectifs et
ces deux dispositifs peuvent être versés
sur l'épargne salariales donc dans ce
dans le graphique a de on a en fait un
petit peu en avance sur les slides si on
peut retourner dans le sac d'avance s'il
vous plaît
on va faire abstraction des slides donc
seule la participation est un dispositif
obligatoire pardon donc selon mes
calculs à partir des données de la DARES
c'est dispositif représente donc que ce
soit la partie patient à l'intéressement
représente à peu près 5% de la
rémunération totale du travail et 2,5%
de la valeur ajoutée avec une
contribution stable depuis les années
donc c'est une petite partie variable de
l'ensemble des rémunérations du travail
et donc c'est pour c'est bien pour cette
raison que les deux premiers chapitres
donc voilà c'est c'est la partie en
rouge merci c'est la partie en rouge
qu'on voit sur ce graphique donc ils
sont la participation et la part de la
participation et de l'intéressement
et donc c'est pour cette raison que les
deux premiers chapitres de l'accord
interprété interprofessionnel rappelle
le cadre existant réglementant les
négociations salariales puisque ce sont
bien les salaires qui sont le cœur du
partage de la valeur
donc néanmoins vu que large partie de la
Corse s'intéresse à ces dispositifs de
participation et d'intéressement
notamment pour en promouvoir
l'utilisation
auprès des petites et moyennes
entreprises on va donc s'intéresser plus
plus plus
en détail à ces deux dispositifs donc en
termes d'utilisation du dispositif la
même enquête de la DARES suggère que 11%
des entreprises ont recours à
l'intéressement et seulement 9% la
participation avec de grandes disparités
en fonction de la taille des entreprises
donc pour les petites entreprises de 10
à 49 salariés seulement 3% des
entreprises on recourt à la
participation en 2019 bien rappeler que
ce dispositif n'est pas obligatoire pour
ces entreprises
donc quel impact de l'extension de ces
dispositifs pour les petites et moyennes
entreprises donc il faut tout d'abord
noter que ces entreprises même si elles
constituent donc le petit témoins des
entreprises l'entreprise de moins de 50
salariés même si elle constitue la plus
grande partie du tissu entre
entrepreneurial français elle ne
représente qu'un tiers de la masse
salariale et un quart de la valeur
ajoutée
ces entreprises sont aussi présentes
dans des secteurs dont la part des
rémunérations du travail dans la valeur
ajoutée et la plus élevée et dont les
bénéfices sont donc plus faibles il en
résulte que mécaniquement les
entreprises ont moins recours à cette
dispositif de partage du fait des
secteurs dans lesquels elles opèrent
donc c'est le cas des secteurs intensifs
en main d'oeuvre comme par exemple le
secteur les deux hébergement et de la
restauration à l'inverse des secteurs
plus intensifs en capital productif
comme le secteur manufacturiers ou les
secteurs plus profitables comme les
industries les starters d'industrie
extractives qui ont plus recours à ces
dispositifs et ou en moyenne les
entreprises ils sont plus grandes
si on regarde plus en détail à
l'intérieur des secteurs
donc ça va être le slide suivant
désolé du coup j'ai un peu perdu notion
des slides on voit que les petites
entreprises ont une part des
rémunérations du travail dans la valeur
ajoutée plus élevé que les autres
entreprises du même secteur donc là
c'est ce qu'on va sur ce graphique à
droite donc qui regarde la part des
rémunérations du travail par taille
d'entreprise donc le point bleu le point
bleu le plus à gauche par exemple va
montrer la part des rémunérations du
travail pour les entreprises de 20 à 50
aux employés et donc plus on avance vers
la droite plus on regarde pour des
entreprises de plus en plus grandes et
on voit bien que la part des
rémunérations du travail dans la valeur
ajoutée de ces entreprises baisse au fur
et à mesure que l'entreprise est plus
grande et ce à l'intérieur d'un secteur
c'est à dire en comparant des
entreprises du même secteur d'activité
on voit que les plus petites entreprises
ont une part des rémunérations du
travail plus importantes que les grandes
entreprises et donc mécaniquement moins
de profits à distribuer et donc auront
moins recours à ces dis l'objectif de
partage de la valeur ajoutée donc
l'ensemble de ces chiffres que ça soit
la composition sectorielle donc que ça
soit les secteurs dans lesquels ces
petites moyennes entreprises
opère ou que ça soit les
caractéristiques même de ces petites
moyennes entreprises à l'intérieur des
secteurs dans lequel elles opèrent mais
également au vu de la contribution de
ces petites et moyennes entreprises à
l'ensemble de la valeur ajoutée
nationale il semble que l'extension des
dispositifs de participation et
d'intéressement permettrait peut-être
une plus forte implication des salariés
dans la gouvernance de ces entreprises
mais aura un impact finalement assez
limité sur les rémunérations du travail
à l'échelle nationale
pour pour conclure donc sur le slide
suivant je vais juste ajouter deux
petits points d'éléments de discussion
donc pour appeler que l'accord national
interprofessionnel s'inscrit donc dans
un contexte de crise de pouvoir d'achat
et donc pour cette raison il a deux
ambitions la première mission de
poursuivre les discussions déjà engagées
autour d'une meilleure répartition de la
valeur ajoutée entre le capital et
travail mais aussi celle de promouvoir
et d'étendre les dispositifs de partage
actuels pour assurer une répartition
plus équitable du coût de la crise
il faut rappeler que ces dispositif
participation intéressante actionnariat
salarié sont des outils initialement
destinés comment ils ont été créés dans
les années 60 à impliquer plus
grandement les salariés à la gouvernance
des entreprises ce ne sont pas des
outils initialement destinés à augmenter
le pouvoir d'achat ni à réduire les
inégalités et donc leur généralisation
au petites et moyennes entreprises en
termes d'impact macroéconomique aura
finalement un impact assez limité sur le
parlate le partage de la valeur ajoutée
nationale
il y a également peut-être un risque
d'effets finalement négatif si cette
extension et ses nouvelles
réglementations ont pour résultat de
freiner la croissance des petites et
moyennes entreprises donc il y a un
article récemment par l'économiste
Philippe à Dion qui regarde l'impact de
l'ensemble des réglementations aux
petites et moyennes entreprises sur leur
croissance et qui montrent que
finalement
les réglementations
freinent plus la croissance de plus des
entreprises et si cela se savait
finalement ça donnerait plus de poids
économiques aux grandes entreprises ou
la part des rémunérations du travail est
plus faible et finalement entraînerait
comme aux États-Unis une baisse par
effet de composition donc du poids
croissant de ces grandes entreprises ou
la part des rémunérations du travail est
plus faible
donc voilà c'était pour mes éléments
d'introduction et je laisse désormais la
parole aux autres intervenants merci
merci beaucoup alors on va repasser
en visio si
Madame posa vous m'entendez
merci à vous
alors déjà je vous prie de m'excuser de
pouvoir être en présentiel mais étant
moi-même chef d'entreprise j'ai une
grosse journée recrutement au sein de
l'entreprise aujourd'hui et je ne
pouvais donc pas être sur Paris puisque
je suis en Normandie en tant que
vice-présidente de la CPE juste pour
mémoire la CPE représente environ 240
000 entreprises et 4 millions de
salariés
alors quel constat on peut faire
notamment pourquoi les TPE PME se sont
pas emparés de ces dispositifs
différents motifs déjà un manque de
connaissances de culture financière
concernant ces dispositifs un manque
d'accompagnement à la fois par les
gestionnaires despargne salariale envers
les TPE PME mais aussi par les
experts-comptables qui ne sont pas
forcément très à l'aise avec ces
dispositifs un des freins les plus gros
dans nos dans nos structures c'est
vraiment le frein collectif de ces
dispositifs freins d'ailleurs souvent
partagés avec nos propres salariés qui
nous disent
moi j'ai pas envie que Pierre touche la
même chose que moi alors qu'il est
souvent absent et que je suis obligé de
le remplacer quand il est pas là et puis
une lourdeur administrative dans la mise
en œuvre des dispositifs
ces dernières années on sait que la loi
pacte a essayé de favoriser le
déploiement de ces de tous ces
dispositifs de partage en revanche
depuis 2020 on est tous concernés par le
covid la guerre en Ukraine l'inflation
les pénuries de recrutement les crises
énergétiques il y a un vrai manque de
visibilité au niveau de nos PME un vrai
frein parfois sur l'activité sur la
rentabilité de l'entreprise et puis il
faut aussi avoir en tête les projets
d'investissement que toutes nos TPE vont
devoir faire pour les transitions
écologiques numériques ce sont des
investissements lourds mais également il
y a des enjeux sociétaux dans le cadre
de la qualité de vie au travail dans le
cadre des mutations écologiques avec des
transferts de métiers et tout ça ne
favorise pas
l'engagement en tout cas des TPE PME de
manière on va dire plus ou moins long
terme et c'est ce qui explique et on y
reviendra d'ailleurs le grand succès de
la prime de partage de valeur qu'on a
depuis ces dernières années
ceci étant une fois qu'on a fait ce
constat ce qu'on peut dire aussi c'est
que les TPE PME elles ont intérêt à
répondre à leurs salariés
aux problématiques de leur salarié je
pense à l'inflation ces derniers mois
qu'il est tous beaucoup pourquoi parce
que déjà ça permet de maintenir un bon
climat social ça permet également de
conserver les compétences dans nos
entreprises et puis d'attirer aussi de
nouveaux talents et ça il faut bien
l'avoir à l'esprit
ça a été évoqué les entreprises en
France partagent déjà beaucoup de leurs
valeurs par le biais des salaires
mais aussi des cotisations et également
tout ce qu'il y a en annexe je pense aux
mutuelles je pense à l'aide au logement
je pense au Chèque Déjeuner chaque
vacances et tous ces dispositifs qui
peuvent exister
on a réalisé au sein de la CPME auprès
de nos adhérents une enquête du premier
au 5 avril 2023 et on a eu 1528 dirige
qui nous ont répondu sur ces 1528
dirigeants 66% des dirigeants ont
augmenté leurs salariés au premier
trimestre 2023 et et là dessus on a
quand même deux dirigeants sur 10 qui
ont appliqué une hausse supérieure à 6%
donc on voit bien qu'il y a une vraie
prise en compte des problématiques et
puis en termes de dispositif
supplémentaire puisque c'est ce qui nous
intéresse à ce jour 42% vont utiliser la
prime de partage de valeur et 24% vont
verser de l'intéressement et de la
participation donc on voit quand même
qu'on est dans une mouvance beaucoup
plus positive que celle qu'on pouvait
connaître il y a 5 à 10 ans
ce projet de loi c'est une énorme
avancée pour les TPE PME
un énorme effort consenti
je vous le rappelle la tpeme c'est pas
une grande entreprise un modèle réduit
c'est pas une entreprise qui fait appel
à de l'épargne publique elles n'ont pas
des super profits et des résultats
exceptionnels de manière très importante
et notamment madame python disait tout à
l'heure sur les entreprises à forte main
d'oeuvre les marges sont souvent très
réduites ce sont des entreprises
patrimoniales beaucoup plus fragiles
financièrement pour lequel le dirigeant
engage souvent très souvent son
patrimoine personnel voire remet de
l'argent quand il y a besoin pour
maintenir l'entreprise à flot et ça je
pense qu'il faut bien l'avoir en tête
dans le cadre de ce projet de loi donc
les efforts qui sont consentis dans
cette année sont pour notre population
vraiment très important
et puis madame python la abordé
également il faut pas oublier aussi que
pour ces dernières ces petites et
moyennes entreprises le rapport
dans l'économie avec les différentes
parties prenantes et souvent très
déséquilibré que ce soit avec des gros
donneurs d'ordre que ce soit les
relations avec l'État avec les
collectivités avec avec toutes les
instances
URSSAF Bercy etc on a quand même pas les
mêmes pouvoirs alors en quoi cette année
répond enfin fait que c'est un effort
considérable pour noterpe je vais
souligner trois points essentiels on va
par débattre on va pas refaire la nuit
dans sa globalité tout d'abord vous
l'avez évoqué c'est cette obligation
nouvelle pour les 11 à 50
de mettre en place un dispositif alors
bien sûr on a mis des conditions
pourquoi parce que on a toujours eu à
cœur de répondre aux problé et
d'accroître de nos salariés et
d'accroître le partage de la richesse en
revanche il faut qu'on assure aussi une
stabilité financière il faut qu'on
permette à nos entreprises de pouvoir
prendre les virages écologiques
économiques et il faut aussi
qu'elle puisse continuer à recruter ce
qui est un des enjeux très forts donc
ces trois des conditions vous les avez
certainement en tête c'est notamment
avoir réalisé un bénéfice fiscal de plus
de 1% pendant trois années consécutives
être sous forme de société et ne pas
avoir mis déjà en place un dispositif
existant
concernant la prise en compte des
résultats exceptionnels là aussi
les tpeme ont fait un un effort en
signant cette année je vous cache pas
que
la
leu le seuil que nous avions demandé
parce que ce qui ce qui est ciblé dans
cette notion de super profit c'est plus
les les entreprises qui font appel à
l'épargne public et qui sortent des
bénéfices exceptionnels et on l'a bien
vu dans les médias ces derniers temps on
avait demandé un seuil nettement
supérieur
à 50 salariés puisque on avait évoqué
pendant un moment un seuil à 5000
salariés ce qui n'a pas été repris dans
cette année donc on est bien sur
les entreprises d'au moins 50 salariés
où il y a une présence d'un délégué
syndical et ça pour nous c'est vraiment
très important
de maintenir ce point dans le projet de
loi pourquoi parce que ça permet quand
même dans les entreprises de notre
taille de conserver
un peu la main au niveau de l'employeur
sur cette définition du risque
exceptionnel pourquoi parce qu'un risque
un résultat pardon pas un risque un
résultat exceptionnel six mois demain je
fais 200 % de mon résultat l'année
prochaine ça va me permettre de
reconstituer mes fonds propres ça va me
permettre de reconstituer ma trésorerie
ça va me permettre de de d'effacer une
mauvaise année que j'ai pu faire l'année
dernière et tout ça ça a des incidences
importantes sur la vie de l'entreprise
puisque je vous rappelle que toutes les
entreprises sont cotées au niveau Banque
de France et qu'une mauvaise cotation
une dégradation ça entraîne des suivis
de banque des banques qui nous lâchent
ça ça entraîne aussi des assureurs
crédits qui nous lâchent et pour
certains parfois la mort de l'entreprise
et ça il faut aussi bien l'avoir en tête
et puis ça permet aussi le fait de
conserver ses fonds s dans l'entreprise
de prévoir les investissements les
recrutements et ça je l'ai déjà dit
plusieurs fois il faut pas oublier que
dans une dans une tpeme on n'a pas tous
la même maturité il y a des entreprises
qui existent depuis 20 30 40 ans qui
sont donc beaucoup plus stables que les
entreprises qui existent depuis un an
deux ans trois ans ça c'est le premier
point et puis on peut aussi avoir de
gros aléas il y a des années qui sont
bonnes et des années qui sont très
mauvaises
enfin dernier point à notre sens très
important pour les TPE PME si la loi
pacte elle a permis de booster
l'actionnariat salarié c'est quand même
un dispositif qui est resté très lourd
pour les TPE et donc cette année permet
un nouvel outil de partage de
valorisation de l'entreprise alors bien
sûr c'est optionnel et ça reste une
possibilité non pas une obligation mais
ça permettra de manière beaucoup plus
facile de faire bénéficier les salariés
de la la croissance de la richesse de
l'entreprise entre une année de
référence 1 et 3 ans après
on nous avait interrogé lors d'audition
précédente sur quelques sur quelques
chiffres que nous n'avions pas notamment
le montant moyen par salarié et le total
versé pour la dernière année disponible
dans l'ensemble des entreprises ça nous
n'avons pas
en revanche ce que l'on sait c'est que
et je l'exprimais c'est qu'il y a un
fort engouement pour le prix la prime de
partage de valeur pourquoi parce que
c'est quelque chose qui est facile à
mettre en oeuvre c'est quelque chose que
l'on peut distribuer quand on a une
visibilité et qui ne nous engage pas sur
une longue durée c'est-à-dire que si
l'année d'après
on perçoit que c'est un une mauvaise
année parce que on a des pertes de
marché parce qu'on a des hausses de coup
on n'est pas tenu il y a pas cet
engagement et il y a pas besoin d'avoir
une visibilité à long terme et c'est
pour ça que la CPE est vraiment très
attaché à la pérennisation de de ce
dispositif
il permet d'autre part une exonération
fiscale
avantageuse pour le salarié et une
exonération sociale pour l'entreprise
voilà en ce qui concerne notamment la
prime de partage de la valeur
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que je voulais vous dire
également je pense que je vous ai dit
l'essentiel et puis je reste bien sûr à
votre disposition pour les questions je
vous remercie beaucoup
on va continuer donc je donne la parole
à Monsieur Perret
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs je voudrais vous
livrer effectivement quelques éléments
de réflexion qui prennent appui sur sur
la mission
effectivement auprès du gouvernement du
ministre de l'économie et du ministre du
Travail depuis 2019 qui m'a été confiée
conjointement avec avec Thibault laxad
que vous connaissez et plus récemment
avec avec Agnès Bricard en faisant à la
fois référence j'allais dire à
l'actualité immédiate et Dieu sait qu'il
est toujours difficile évidemment de de
l'analyser par définition avec recul
mais aussi justement en prenant
peut-être un peu de un peu de distance
par rapport à cette actualité autour de
quatre points que je voudrais partager
avec vous le premier d'abord justement
en référence à un essai très synthétique
de mise en perspective historique pour
rappeler que la question du partage de
la valeur
est loin sans faux un sujet très court
termiste qui pourrait être perçu comme
une volonté
à travers son placement dans le débat
une volonté de dépasser la réforme des
retraites on est au contraire sur un
sujet qui est très ancré historiquement
et qui va d'ailleurs beaucoup plus loin
et je tiens quand même à le rappeler à
la légende urbaine qui fait remonter
notre problématique au général de Gaulle
et au fameux ordonnances de 1959 et de
1967 sur l'intéressement et la
participation on est sur un sujet qui a
émergé en fait il y a extrêmement
longtemps on trouvait déjà
à travers les propos d'Alexis
Tocqueville au 19e siècle les prémices
de cette question du partage de la
valeur je rappelle que Alexis
Tocqueville dans son second mémoire sur
le paupérisme qui date de 1837 se posait
déjà la question suivante à mon avis
tout le problème à résoudre disait-il et
celui de trouver un moyen de donner à
l'ouvrier industriel comme au petit
agriculteur l'espoir et les habitudes de
la propriété donc on est bien déjà dans
une ambition Hist d'associations en fait
des salariés
à aux résultats au capital et à la
décision dans l'entreprise et cette
tradition finalement du partage de la
valeur qu'on retrouve dans notre pays
sera partagé j'allais dire de façon très
schématique tant à gauche qu'à droite on
sait que les socialistes utopiques
derrière Proudhon ou Fourier avaient
déjà des réflexions sur le partage des
dividendes et de l'autre côté ou si
j'ose dire en tout cas du côté du
catholicisme social il y avait aussi
déjà une pregnance très forte sur ces
sujets alors c'est vrai que le sujet a
pris son essor effectivement avec la
période gaullienne qui a vraiment permis
de construire je dirais les fonds
bâtissements de notre sujet à travers
les ordonnances que j'ai citées et on
voit bien qu'aujourd'hui on ne se pose
plus seulement la question essentielle
de la création de richesse mais aussi
celle du partage et de la de la
redistribution dans j'allais dire une
optique aussi de de trouver un une
nouvelle voie un capitalisme qui à
parfois serait efficace sur le plan
économique et juste sur le plan social
je refais un évidemment cette parenthèse
historique pour cette fois-ci en créer
mon propos dans l'actualité mais au fond
cette question du partage de la valeur
et le projet de loi qui était présenté
hier au conseil du ministre fait
apparaître en tout cas dans la période
très contemporaine me semble-t-il une
certaine forme de continuité de l'État
sur cette question du partage de la
valeur il me semble que depuis
effectivement le premier quinquennat de
l'actuel président de la République on
voit vraiment une ambition à la fois
renouvelée et sans cesse approfondie
autour de deux grands objectifs qui sont
à la fois celui de la démocratisation
d'ailleurs d'un meilleur accès au
dispositif de la partage de partage de
la valeur qui d'ailleurs l'axe 2 du
projet de loi qui a été présenté hier en
conseil des ministres
un deuxième objectif qui me semble être
également très récurrent qui est celui
de la simplification des dispositifs et
qui permet d'ailleurs ce faisant
d'atteindre potentiellement le premier
et qu'on retrouve dans l'axe 3 du projet
de loi qui a été présenté hier et sans
doute également je dirais plus un moyen
un objectif intermédiaire qu'un objectif
final qui est aussi au fur et à mesure
quand même des dispositifs législatifs
et réglementaires d'alléger la charge
associée à ces dispositifs en
réfléchissant toujours plus loin en
matière de défiscalisation même si on
leur a tous observé le contexte de
finances publiques que traverse la
France réduit peut-être un peu l'ardeur
du législateur sur ce point mais pour
autant en tout cas c'est vrai que depuis
la loi pacte a été rappelée par Madame
posa tout à l'heure en passant par la
loi ASAP d'accélération de la
simplification de l'action publique en
2020 jusqu'au projet de loi actuelle en
passant par la loi pouvoir d'achat 2022
on voit cette continuité de l'action
publique autour du partage avec
peut-être une fracture que vous avez
indiquée tout à l'heure madame python
avec l'émergence du pouvoir d'achat
parce que c'est vrai que la
préoccupation pour le pouvoir d'achat
pose la question de l'usage de ces
dispositifs et leur finalités est-ce
qu'on est bien toujours comme le
prévoyait législateur initialement dans
une logique de constituer une épargne
qui peut alimenter le financement de
l'économie et préparer l'avenir de
français ou est-ce qu'on est aussi dans
une logique de redistribution immédiate
pour compenser finalement des pertes de
pouvoir d'achat qui peuvent être en
effet associés au contexte
inflationniste et ça c'est probablement
aussi source de confusion me semble-t-il
notamment à l'occasion la loi pouvoir
d'achat qui a essayé de trouver
justement dans le dans l'épargne
salariale un vecteur supplémentaire de
distribution du pouvoir d'achat encore
qu'il les fait avec évidemment un souci
d'équilibre important c'est le deuxième
point que je voulais partager c'est
celui de la continuité de l'action en
matière de partage de la valeur depuis
plusieurs années maintenant si je
porte mon regard sur la corde nationale
interprofessionnelle du 10 février
dernier et sa traduction dans le projet
de loi qui a été présenté hier et qui
entend retranscrire je cite les termes
de la première ministre fidèlement et
exhaustivement et bien la corne
nationale interprofessionnelle vient je
voudrais en tout cas insister sur
plusieurs avancées avant peut-être de
souligner les points d'attention qui
pourraient être aussi les vôtres au
moment de l'examen parlementaire de ce
projet de loi je crois comme Madame posa
en effet que le texte a le mérite de
proposer des avancées sur au moins 5
points le premier donc je ne vais pas
être long puisqu'il a été dit c'est la
question d'oser traiter le sujet de la
généralisation en dessous de 50 salariés
et de le faire sans doute avec quand
même un certain volontarisme une
certaine lucidité un certain
volontarisme puisqu'il y a quand même il
est question effectivement d'aller vers
on va dire une certaine forme
d'obligation pour les entreprises de 11
à 49 de disposer d'au moins un
dispositif de partage de la valeur mais
avec le choix laissé à l'employeur de
réfléchir est-ce que je mets en place de
l'intéressement de la participation ou
de l'abondement voire du partage voire
de la prime de partage de la valeur je
parle aussi de lucidité parce que le
texte prévoit effectivement de tenir
compte de la santé financière des
entreprises avec la limite qui a été
posée rappelée tout à l'heure sur ce
bénéfice fiscal de d'au moins 1% pendant
trois ans qui exclu effectivement qu'on
mette une pression supplémentaire sur
des entreprises de petite taille qui
n'auraient pas les moyens de distribuer
davantage donc ça il me semble c'est un
premier à qui potentielle de la réforme
le deuxième acquis c'est aussi me
semble-t-il d'aligner en partie la prime
de partage de la valeur sur les autres
régimes de l'épargne salariale j'avais
beaucoup dénoncé au cours des derniers
mois le fait que précisément la prime de
partage de la valeur servent uniquement
un objectif de très court terme en terme
de pouvoir d'achat le texte prévoit la
possibilité pour le bénéficiaire de
cette prime à l'avenir de pouvoir soit
la toucher immédiatement dans un autre
type de pouvoir d'achat soit de pouvoir
la placer sur un plan d'épargne et donc
de réaligner finalement partiellement au
moins la prime de partage de la valeur
sur les autres dispositifs comme
l'intéressement et la participation le
troisième acquis je pense que c'est
évidemment la prise en compte de la
notion de résultat exceptionnel avec
évidemment toute la difficulté
d'interpréter de définir ce qu'est ce
résultat exceptionnel et je crois que
c'est un bon point que de voir que dans
ce projet de loi on passe d'une
définition même du résultat exceptionnel
par l'employeur à une définition qui
sera ouverte à la négociation en
entreprise et donc aussi à une
discussion un dialogue entre l'employeur
et les salariés le quatrième acquis me
semble-t-il du projet de loi qui a été
présenté c'est aussi de penser à
intégrer au moins un et peut-être
plusieurs critères RSE dans les accords
d'intéressement et au fond finalement et
aussi de promouvoir l'épargne verte de
manière finalement à se servir aussi des
dispositifs d'épargne salariale comme un
levier supplémentaire de notre
transition énergétique et écologique et
je crois que c'est très important
aujourd'hui à l'heure de de
l'accélération j'ai à dire de la
décarbonation et la transition
écologique en particulier de nos PME
puisque 33000 PME industriels devront
être décarbonés de donner des incitatifs
supplémentaires aux employeurs pour
s'engager dans cette voie je voudrais
aussi très rapidement reprendre le
dernier acquis que vous avez souligné
madame posa sur le fait de pouvoir faire
avancer à travers ce texte la cause de
l'actionnariat salarié c'est l'axe 4 du
projet de loi en adaptant ces modalités
aux contraintes des PME parce que c'est
vrai que souvent l'actionnariat salarié
est perçu dans les plus petites
entreprises comme relevant encore de
dispositifs de modalités opérationnelles
extrêmement complexes le projet de loi
de ce point de vue introduit une
certaine simplification alors pour
autant je voudrais terminer avec vous
sur ce quatrième point je crois qu'il y
a aussi une attention à avoir au moment
de de l'examen parlementaire sur
différents aspects sensibles du projet
de loi d'abord la question du principe
de non substitution entre les pagnes
salariale et les salaires vous savez que
c'est une préoccupation très forte des
organisations
syndicales donc de bien veiller non
seulement j'allais dire à l'affirmation
dans le texte de ce principe de non
substitution mais aussi à la capacité
réelle qu'on aura de vérifier la bonne
application pour les entreprises de
cette non substitution parce que comment
est-ce qu'on fait concrètement pour
vérifier que un employeur qui voudrait
augmenter les primes d'intéressement et
de participation ne le fait pas au
détriment de l'augmentation des salaires
c'est quand même très compliqué il va
falloir suivre évidemment de façon très
fine les négociations annuelles
obligatoires et essayer de repérer et de
faire des des études sur ce sujet on
sait qu'une étude de 2015 avait montré
quand même que
pour au moins 15% il y avait bien des
effets de substitution entre l'épargne
salariale et les salaires et ce qu'on
peut observer c'est évidemment
aujourd'hui que les salaires en dépit du
rythme plus élevé qu'ils suivent depuis
la fin de l'année dernière ont bien du
mal encore à rattraper l'augmentation
des prix donc attention de ne pas
j'allais dire apporter des solutions de
très court terme sous forme d'épargne
salariale plutôt que des solutions
pérennes en termes d'augmentation des
rémunérations fixes c'est un premier
point d'attention mon deuxième point
d'attention c'est à nouveau et j'y
reviens sur la question de la prime de
partage de la valeur et la pérennisation
des avantages qui sont associés
c'est-à-dire à la fois tout ce qui
relève de l'exonération de la CSG la
CRDS et également de l'impôt sur le
revenu le projet de loi prévoit le
maintien et la pérennisation de ses
avantages dans les entreprises de moins
de 50 salariés pour les salariés jusqu'à
3 SMIC jusqu'au 31 décembre 2026 je
crains
donc c'est quand même un point
d'attention et un point d'équilibre à
trouver sur le plan législatif le
troisième point c'est un point
d'attention sur skin figure pas sur le
projet de loi et qui peut aussi
alimenter votre réflexion notamment en
termes de simplification je pense que
par définition on ne va jamais assez
loin en matière de simplification même
si évidemment
les plus subtils d'entre nous auront
observé que pour simplifier il faut
légiférer et que la législation
introduit de la complexité mais enfin si
on veut sortir de ce schéma moi je me
rends compte pour l'avoir analysé avec
Thibault laxa des et Agnès Bricard que
quand vous devez produire un accord
d'épargne salariale vous êtes encore
confronté un document touffu d'au moins
qu'un spage que nous pourrions imaginer
ramener probablement à deux pages avec
quelques annexes moins dissuasives pour
l'employeur afin de passer à l'action
c'est un premier point sur lequel on
peut évidemment travailler ensemble on a
déjà un
modèle qu'on a transmis aux équipes de
Bercy le ministère du Travail
probablement réfléchir aussi sur la
sécurisation des accords de partage à la
valeur ils le sont davantage parce que
là le contrôle a été simplifié entre les
ex directs les drets et les et les
urssafs mais il y a peut-être à imaginer
encore un droit à l'erreur qui
permettrait à un employeur qui a pu
commettre une erreur dans sa dans la
rédaction de son accord parce qu'il
aurait oublié par exemple un
contributeur partiel de sa société un
jardinier qui intervient deux heures par
mois et qui n'aurait pas été intégré
dans l'accord d'intéressement et bien
sans affaire sans avoir à entraîner la
caducité j'allais dire de l'accord de
pouvoir reconnaître qu'il a la
possibilité de le modifier sans
engendrer effectivement ça ça remise en
question complète donc en matière de
simplification il y a encore beaucoup
beaucoup de travail devant nous je
termine sur peut-être deux ou trois
points d'attention supplémentaires le
quatrième c'est probablement envie de
veiller si j'ose dire à la conformité
des amendements que vous proposerez à
l'accord national interprofessionnel je
sais que l'exécutif est évidemment très
sensible au fait qu'on respecte aussi le
dialogue qui a pu être établi et qui
était très fructueux avec avec les
partenaires sociaux et puis enfin je
terminerai sur deux points qui me
paraissent assez important c'est au fond
d'abord celui de la de l'ambition qu'on
veut se donner à travers ce nouveau
texte moi je suis toujours très frappé
par le fait que on a des objectifs assez
fort en matière d'épargne scénariale
mais on les quantifie pas vraiment
aujourd'hui l'encours d'épargne
salariale si je reprends le chiffre de
l'été 2022 c'est environ 150 milliards
d'euros alors 150 milliards d'euros à
quoi il faut le rapporter à quoi il faut
le comparer probablement au chiffre de
l’épargne réglementée et donc on
s'aperçoit que 150 milliards c'est même
pas 10% de l'encours de l'assurance vie
donc si on veut vraiment que l'épargne
salariale
tout comme l'épargne retraite pèse dans
la préparation de l'avenir des Français
dans la possibilité de constituer un
matelas qui va j'allais dire compléter
celui de l'épargne par répartition il
faut qu'on se donne des ambitions de
politique économique sur ce sujet assez
important et qui renvoie à la question
de l'élargissement de la de la
couverture finalement de l'épargne
salariale dans toute les entreprises les
chiffres ont été rappelés tout à l'heure
plus on descend dans la taille des
entreprises et plus cette couverture est
faible et puis je terminerai par un
dernier point qui est la question de
l'accompagnement je crois que madame
posaille a fait également référence tout
à l'heure là on est dans le non
législatif mais on est dans le très
pragmatique et en réalité dans la bonne
application de ce futur projet de loi ce
qui va également peser au-delà des des
décrets et des textes réglementaires qui
vont veiller à s'abonner application
c'est aussi l'application sur le terrain
et le fait que les employeurs et les
salariés ne soient pas livrés à
eux-mêmes pour mettre en œuvre des
accords d'épargne salariale il y a un
gros travail qui a été fait il y a
notamment le site de l'URSSAF qui
propose maintenant un accompagnement pas
à pas des employeurs qui veulent rédiger
un accord c'est très très bien mais en
réalité cela suppose aussi que
l'employeur aille vers le site de
l'URSSAF ce qui est pas toujours
forcément une démarche évidente à faire
quand on est employeur mais en revanche
il y a des accompagnateurs naturels du
développement des dispositifs de partage
de la valeur il y a évidemment ceux qui
les distribuent les acteurs financiers
mais également tous les grands réseaux
d'accompagnement des plus petites
entreprises et je veux réinsister ici
sur la place me semble-t-il des experts
comptables ils sont environ 20.000 dans
notre pays au plus près des TPE et je
veux insister aussi sur le rôle des
chambres de commerce qui peuvent aussi
évidemment apporter une contribution en
matière d'accompagnement je dirais
qu'aujourd'hui l'éducation financière en
matière d'épargne salariale chez les
experts et dans les chambres de commerce
et peut-être insuffisante et qu'elle est
sans doute un peu plus faible en matière
d'intéressement qu'en matière de
participation parce que la participation
repose sur une éducation financière
qu'on sait corps de métier mais
l'intéressement qui est un sujet
beaucoup plus vaste et qui peut nous
conduire comme on le voit à introduire
des critères industriels des critères
commerciaux mais aussi des critères avec
des indicateurs sociétaux ou
environnementaux et évidemment un sujet
un petit peu moins maîtrisé par ces
différents corps de métiers donc moi
pour terminer je dirais que j'ai
beaucoup d'espoir sur
l'ambition et les nouvelles orientations
qui se dégagent de ce projet de loi
issu de la corne national
interprofessionnel mais le diable et
sera évidemment dans les détails et dans
les détails de vos amendements qui
doivent à la fois me semble-t-il devoir
respecter l'esprit de ce projet de loi
m'éveiller aussi à ce qu'on aille
peut-être encore un petit peu plus loin
notamment en matière de simplification
pour aller plus loin dans l'accès et
dans la démocratisation des dispositifs
de partage de la valeur merci beaucoup
merci merci à chacun de ces exposer
préliminaires très complet
alors je suis pas sûr à des questions
peut-être en tout cas simplement un
témoignage parce que le hasard fait que
j'ai échangé avec ma vice-présidente et
on a découvert tous les deux avoir mis
en place des accords d'intéressement
chacun
en fonction de notre histoire pour moi
assez lointain puisque j'ai bien en
place un accord d'intéressement en 1975
lors de la création de mon entreprise
immédiatement il y avait aucun
environnement possible l'URSSAF même
l'imaginer pas ça et donc en bidouillant
les textes de 59 qui était pour la très
grande industrie et l'appliquer à une à
l'époque une TPE donc ça fonctionne et
j'ai pu servir ainsi pendant toute la
durée de vie de mes activités tous les
ans
une part du résultat salariés
on multipliant après les possibilités et
puis pour Martine Berthet c'est en 2010
qu'elle a mis en place dans une activité
commerciale bref c'est possible dans les
petites entreprises
c'est aussi un outil de management qu'il
faut avoir en tête je le dis une façon
confraternelle à la représentante de la
CGP PME CPME parce que là aussi c'est
l'histoire bref merci de vos de vos
interventions je me tourne vers mes
collègues alors peut-être Michel Calvet
Michel cadalat sénateur du Finistère
merci beaucoup de l'ensemble de ces
éclairages les chiffres donnés par
Madame piton montre bien le chemin à
parcourir ces 3% des entreprises de 11
49 salariés en bénéficie il y a
effectivement tout un potentiel à
développer et l'accompagnement que vous
venez d'évoquer sera absolument
nécessaire
je voulais sur ce point vous demander
quel pouvait être les solutions pour ce
qui concerne les entreprises de 0 enfin
de 1 à 10 salariés en fait parce que
quantitativement ce sont les entreprises
les plus nombreuses est-ce qu'il est
possible d'envisager des choses
également dans le dans le texte ensuite
vous avez évoqué Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
donc
la question de la hiérarchisation entre
les différents dispositifs et notamment
le fait que le dispositif lié à la prime
de partage à la valeur puisse être
privilégiée par les entreprises de par
le coût moindre effectivement alors à
cela on peut peut-être considérer que ce
dispositif n'a qu'une durée limitée en
2026 et que peut-être que l'objectif
doit plutôt être qu'une entreprise
s'engagent dans le dispositif de la du
partage de la valeur et puis qu'ensuite
un autre dispositif prendra le volet
mais
est-ce qu'il ne faudrait pas de de ce
fait là quand même revoir le dispositif
de la prime de partage à la valeur pour
peut-être réinstituer une partie alors
je sais pas la CRDS ou la la CSG ou bien
revoir le niveau de la des contributions
du forfait social pour ce qui concerne
les autres dispositifs c'est un sujet
que nous avions évoqué lors de l'examen
de la loi pacte en 2019 et ici au Sénat
nous étions plutôt partisans
effectivement de diminuer à 10% le
montant du forfait social pour inciter à
encourager les entreprises à
instaurer alors
durant cette loi pacte nous avions
également beaucoup réfléchi sur la
question de la participation c'est la
Formule 1 qui pose problème
alors jusqu'à présent on n'a pas trouvé
de solutions qui permettent de part de
façon satisfaisante à la formule de la
participation est-ce qu'il n'est pas
tant quand même
maintenant il y a l'occasion de ce texte
de revoir la formule et est-ce que des
travaux ont été conduits là-dessus ou
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres solutions qui
émergent qui permettent d'avoir une
formule qui permette de d'éviter pour
certains entreprises que cela n'est des
résultats
contre-productifs mais que le dispositif
puisse être le plus largement partagé
comme vous
je pense que ce sont des éléments de
fidélisation est qui sont absolument
nécessaires dans le contexte de l'emploi
que nous examinons par ailleurs
d'ailleurs au sein de la délégation pour
les entreprises mais qui posent problème
à beaucoup d'entreprises et ce sont des
éléments qui permettent de fidéliser les
salariés dans l'entreprise mais à mon
avis il faut qu'on ait une projection
quand même sur le long terme c'est à
dire qu'en privilégie l'épargne sur le
long terme au détriment de de de la
réponse au pouvoir d'achat qui comme
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure à mon
avis est plutôt à traiter par le biais
des salaires
merci qui veut répondre monsieur Perret
peut-être et puis
en fonction des termes le terme le bon
terme à choisir peut-être
ces PME après madame Bosa allez-y
monsieur merci je crois que vous vos
trois questions sont en réalité très
complémentaires et me permettre de
souligner d'abord qu'il y a pour moi
en voulant bien faire
et en créant de nombreuses instruments
de partage de la valeur on s'expose
aussi un risque de de manque de
lisibilité et comme je l'ai un petit peu
dit tout à l'heure de concurrence entre
les différents dispositifs alors c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui
on a le choix on a l'intéressement dans
la participation on a l'abondement on a
la prime de partage de la valeur et je
crois que le vrai risque c'est que les
employeurs ne sachent plus vraiment par
où commencer alors vous allez me dire au
dessus de 50 salariés on a la
participation qui est obligatoire et on
a l'intéressement qui s'applique de
façon facultative quel que soit la
taille évidemment quelle que soit le
secteur d'activité donc ça c'est la base
de départ par rapport à cette base de
départ on se rend compte quand même que
le cœur finalement de notre
problématique c'est celui de la
généralisation dans les moins de 50
salariés
et dans la question des moins de 50
salariés on voit que le législateur
distingue finalement deux situations la
question des 11 à 49 et la question
j'allais dire non traitée
des moins de 11
beaucoup beaucoup de beaucoup d'ancres à
couler effectivement sur ce sur ces
questions de savoir quelle dispositif on
devait privilégier dans les moins de 50
et comment répondre à la spécificité des
très petites entreprises
on voit que sur la question déjà de 11 à
l'accord national interprofessionnel
a été un peu hésitant quand on lit son
article 6 et son article 7 on se rend
compte que d'un côté on dit il y aura un
dispositif au moins de partage de la
valeur dans le dans les entreprises de
11 à 49 mais choisissez votre dispositif
puis un article suivant qui dit ce
serait quand même plutôt bien que ce
soit la participation mais après tout
dépend un peu de votre santé financière
bon globalement on a appréhendé avec une
certaine souplesse un certain
pragmatisme la situation entre 11 et 49
pour répondre à votre question sur les
moins de 11 c'est vrai que le cas est
fréquemment évoqué que finalement la
santé financière des TPE le fait que au
fond c'est on peut pas diriger organiser
et manager une entreprise de moins de 10
salariés comme on le ferait avec une
entreprise de 50 ou à fortiori de 150
salariés fait qu'on est un peu mal à
l'aise moi j'aurais tendance à penser
c'est ma pensée personnelle n'engage que
moi même que il faut il faudrait mettre
non seulement de la lumière mais la
lisibilité à tous les étages et que
précisément la prime de partage de la
valeur
gagnerait à être très fléchés sur les
entreprises de moins de 11 salariés
c'est à dire que pour éviter de rajouter
de la complexité à ces entreprises qui
ont contraire besoin qu'on les aide à ce
que tout se passe très facilement sur le
plan administratif et aussi parce que la
représentation sociale dans les
entreprises de moins de 11 à la fois
n'est pas la même et n'obéit pas au même
règle je pense que si on affichait la
prime de partage de la valeur en la
recentrant vers les moins de 11 que
ensuite on dédié un peu l'intéressement
au moins peut-être à titre expérimental
vers l'ambition écologique et sociétale
pour lui redonner également du lustre
parce que vous voyez bien qu'il y a un
risque que finalement
d'un côté la participation s'étendent
plus petites entreprises et que les
employeurs ne risquent de délaisser
finalement un petit peu l'intéressement
donc moi je serai favorable à cette
remise en perspective là la prime de
partage de la valeur dans les moins de
11 le recentrage de l'intéressement sur
l'ambition écologique et sociétale et
puis le maintien de la situation
actuelle avec la partie passion
obligatoire dans les entreprises de plus
de 50 salariés ça c'est un premier point
le deuxième point c'est au fond la
question que vous avez aussi mentionné
du forfait social je pense que la
question du forfait social c'est d'abord
une question de finance publique
que de mon côté et avec les les deux
autres ambassadeurs ont appelé des
depuis plusieurs années sur le fait que
la suppression du forfait social
puisse également s'étendre au-delà de
250 salariés parce qu'on a quand même un
enjeu d'extension des dispositifs
d'épargne salariale dans les ETI
et au moins peut-être avoir un une
sortie un peu en sifflet de cette
affaire de manière à ce que peut-être on
est un forfait social à 15 puis à 10% ou
plutôt à 10 puis à 15% en fonction de la
taille des ETI parce que je crois qu'il
y a une ETI qui aurait 251 salariés et
50,01 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires elle est plus proche d'une
PME que de noter en revanche on a des
grosses ETI qui ressemblent plus à des
grands groupes et là en effet le
traitement fiscal doit peut-être pas
être le même donc on a le sujet par en
haut d'arriver à se donner des marges de
manœuvre en termes de finances publiques
pour pouvoir trouver les centaines de
millions les 4 milliards probablement
qu'il faudrait pour faire tomber
progressivement le forfait social dans
les petites ETI et puis on a la question
de l'alignement des seuils en dessous de
250 puisqu'en réalité la loi pacte et la
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2019 disait il y a
suppression du forfait social en dessous
de 250 c'est pas tout à fait vrai
puisque c'est pas la même le traitement
fiscal n'est pas le même pour la
participation l'intéressement et
l'abondement donc il reste encore des
seuils et donc je pense qu'il serait
bien en effet d'avoir un seuil unique de
250 qui simplifierait également la donne
et puis enfin pour répondre à votre
dernière question de mon côté sur la
question de la formule de participation
qui est un vrai serpent de mer je
rappelle que autour de 2018 le copieras
qui était l'instance que réunissait
fréquemment l'exécutif autour d'un
député avait fait des propositions en
matière de simplification de la formule
de participation à ma connaissance
ces réflexions sur la simplification la
formule de participation ont toujours
échoué sur ce que vous avez un petit peu
rappelé c'est à dire l'impact que ça
pouvait avoir secteur par secteur et en
particulier
le l'impact que ça pouvait voir sur
l'industrie l'impact défavorable sur
l'industrie alors c'est vrai que nous on
évoque souvent l'idée de pouvoir aller
faire quelque chose de qui pourrait
ressembler à une révision autour du du
bénéfice net comptable plutôt que le
bénéfice fiscal
et peut-être de supprimer le demi de la
formule qui représentait enfin qui était
déjà présent à l'époque de depuis
l'ordonnance de 67 du général de Gaulle
mais on se rend compte que voilà on
n'est pas pour le moment arrivé à
trouver une formule de simplification
enfin de participation simplifiée qui
soit qui fasse qu'on s'insus donc je
pense que vous avez raison il faut
continuer à travailler sur ce point mais
on n'a pas trouvé la recette magique à
ce stade
madame posa peut-être sur cet aspect de
les seuils et les échéances avec plaisir
donc sur sur les entreprises de de 1 à
11 salariés effectivement lors de cette
négociation ça a beaucoup été évoqué
la difficulté que l'on a sur cette
catégorie d'entreprise c'est d'une part
elles ont souvent une forme juridique
différente
qui fait que le résultat de l'entreprise
c'est souvent la rémunération du
dirigeant quand il reste quelque chose
et donc à ce titre c'est c'est ça peut
aussi
comment dire
c'est des contraintes supplémentaires
qui qui faut prendre en compte
sur la hiérarchisation des dispositifs
en fait ça a été aussi évoqué on trouve
que participation intéressement et PPV
c'est vraiment trois dispositifs
différents qui sont très complémentaires
à la fois en termes de vie de maturité
de l'entreprise mais aussi de ce que
vous voulez vous parliez tout à l'heure
de stratégie managériale de ce que vous
souhaitez impulser au sein de votre
entreprise notamment dans les moins de
50 ou la participation n'est pas
obligatoire
et la PPV on l'a dit tout à l'heure elle
est simple effectivement à mettre en
oeuvre nous on est très attaché à ce
qu'elle reste dans le SCOP des moins de
50 pourquoi parce que l'intéressement
peut être très lourd et aujourd'hui en
tout cas à ce stade
les entreprises de moins de 5 ans ne
bénéficient pas d'un conseil et d'un
accompagnement suffisant des
gestionnaires d'épargne salariale des
accompagnateur s voire des experts
comptables pour trouver au plus juste
les formules d'intéressement qui qui
pourrait correspondre le mieux à leur
objectif stratégique et managérial
et là on peut se poser la question aussi
et ça a été évoqué aussi les branches
ont certainement un rôle à jouer en
proposant et je pense que certaines le
font déjà des accords types avec des
indicateurs qui soient spécifiques au
secteur
concernant
concernant le
forfait social
là effectivement il y a un sujet le
forfait social on l'a évoqué également
pendant notre négociation
évidemment on n'est pas tombé d'accord
déjà il rentrait pas forcément dans le
cadre
de la négociation dans le sens où ils ne
permettait pas
aux salariés en direct de bénéficier de
quelque chose en supplie de
supplémentaire en tout cas de partager
en direct avec les salariés
la croissance de la richesse de
l'entreprise comme le disait monsieur
Perret c'est plus une question de
finance publique la question de
lisibilité des seuils a été un sujet qui
a été abordé alors évidemment vous
imaginez bien qu'on n'est pas tous
tombés d'accord
nous on prenait plutôt au niveau des
entreprises la suppression du forfait
social notamment sur sur les moins de 5
les moins de 50 et 250 avoir un forfait
qui soit complètement
unique et à zéro les salariés disaient
nous on voudrait plutôt un forfait à vin
partout peut-être que voilà la vérité
était un peu au milieu des deux mais en
tout état de cause on a considéré que
l'objectif de cet accord c'était non pas
de de répondre à cette problématique de
questions des finances publiques même si
ça a été abordé mais plutôt de comment
on partage davantage la richesse de
l'entreprise avec les salariés qui
participent à la création de cette
richesse
enfin sur la formule de participation je
rejoins complètement ce qui a été dit
par Monsieur Perret je faisais
d'ailleurs partie des travaux du copiésa
à l'époque
ça a été abordé
plusieurs fois cette formule elle est
lisible à la fois pour le salarié mais
aussi pour le dirigeant c'est-à-dire
qu'un entrepreneur qui a moins de 50
salariés qui se dit demain j'aimerais
bien mettre en place un accord de
participation parce que je veux je veux
que tout le monde touche la même chose
dans les mêmes conditions
voilà et ben dire à ses salariés vous
allez pouvoir avoir tant de ce qui va
sortir c'est impossible parce qu'elle
est très complexe en revanche on n'a pas
trouvé
de solutions idéales pour ne pas
comment dire
impacter certains secteurs d'activité
par contre dans les entreprises on est
très attaché à ce que la notion de
bénéfice fiscal
demeure pourquoi parce que quand tu vous
fêtes une mauvaise année ça permet
l'année suivante qui est meilleure et
parfois il en faut plusieurs de de
lisser la perte que vous avez pu faire
et de de récupérer une santé financière
avant de pouvoir distribuer les gains
que vous avez pu faire
merci
merci beaucoup
madame piton peut-être un commentaire
sur ce pour mettre en perspective avec
ce que vous nous avez présenté est-ce
que ça fera
un changement brutal ou à terme ou sur
les différentes courbes que vous avez
présenté ce que vous avez
monté sur les petites entreprises de
moins de 10 salariés malheureusement on
a très peu de données à notre
disposition pour pouvoir étudier
l'impact donc malheureusement j'ai pas
beaucoup de choses à dire à ce sujet
[Musique]
oui merci président merci à vous pour
votre exposé peut-être une question sur
les conditions de l'article 2 des
entreprises qui auraient une forme
sociétaire et dont le bénéfice fiscal et
au moins 1% du chiffre d'affaires est-ce
qu'il y a beaucoup
j'ai pas les informations de
statistiquement d'entreprise de plus de
11 salariés qui ne sont pas sous forme
sociétaire voilà premier point de
méthodologie statistique et en effet je
partage tout à fait monsieur Perrin
votre avis sur le fait de bien
distinguer la question salariale de la
question du partage de la valeur parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a quand même voilà
dans notre pays un quart des Français
qui disent avoir des difficultés
financières même pour s'alimenter donc
on a vraiment cette question de pouvoir
d'achat et du voilà
nécessaire revalorisation des salaires
et il faudrait pas que que ce soit
simplement un pisalé et vous avez évoqué
tout à l'heure une épargne qui
permettrait éventuellement de compléter
la retraite il ne faudrait pas que ce
c'est possible finalement
puisse
pas direct une forme de retraite par
capitalisation mais comme on sait que
les conditions de retraite vont se
durcir notamment avec la dernière
réforme je pense que laisser penser ça
pourrait également présenter un risque
je vous remercie
peut-être madame posa je reviens vers
vous sur ces sujets particuliers
oui alors sur la forme sociétaire pour
les entreprises supérieures à 11 j'ai
pas les chiffres j'ai pas de
statistiques je pense que quand on a
passé le cap de 10 souvent on se met
plutôt déjà en forme de société
notamment sous forme de SARL mais là
peut-être
peut-être que
Infogreffe pourrait nous donner des
statistiques au niveau au niveau
national en ce qui concerne la
distinction entre rémunération sous
forme de salaire et prime de partage de
la valeur
Lagny l'a bien rappelé et d'ailleurs on
le voit dans les dans les premiers
articles où on dit bien que ça ne doit
pas se substituer on a rappelé
d'ailleurs l'obligation pour les pour
les branches de de
faire leur négociation et également de
respecter
y compris
dans les compétences c'est dans
l'évaluation des grilles on rappelle
bien l'obligation à notre sens
les deux ne peuvent enfin en tout cas
l'objectif de cette année c'était pas du
tout de mettre en place des dispositifs
pour se substituer
hausse de rémunération et d'ailleurs
dans la statistique que je vous ai
donnée on voit bien que ce n'est pas le
cas puisqu'on a quand même sur les les
dirigeants qui nous ont répondu 66% qui
ont augmenté leurs salariés au premier
trimestre alors deux manettes de manière
naturelle ou forcées par les accords de
branches mais en tout cas c'est quand
même 66% des dirigeants qui qui ont dit
avoir augmenté leurs salariés et malgré
ces hausses on a quand même aussi 42%
qui vont utiliser la prime de partage de
la valeur et 24% qui verseront aussi
l'intéressement de la participation donc
on voit bien
on voit bien qu'il y a les choses sont
très complémentaires alors on évitera
pas quelqu'un parlait tout à l'heure de
je crois que c'est Monsieur Perret qui
disait qu'il y avait une étude en 2015
qui avait montré qu'il y avait eu à peu
près 15% un peu d'effet d'aubaine et de
substitution c'est comme tout on évitera
pas on fera pas du 100% mais en tout cas
je pense que dans la tête des dirigeants
en tout cas ceux qui sont vertueux l'un
ne compensent pas l'autre en revanche
c'est vrai quand vous vous engagez sur
une hausse de salaire par exemple
l'individuel dans une TPE vous prenez un
peu votre élan parce que vous savez que
c'est très récurrent qui a des charges
dessus qui sont qui peuvent être
importantes
et donc vous le faites si vous avez à
peu près une visibilité
ou si c'est des personnes
pour lesquelles
[Musique]
il y a dans les moins de 50 une notion
un peu du je vais pas dire de la
rémunération mérite mais en tout cas de
la prise en compte de l'investissement
de chacun qu'il faut pas non plus
complètement à mon sens occulté et
d'ailleurs nos salariés le souhaitent
également pour être tout à fait honnête
merci sur ce thème là pas d'intervention
si non allez-y non j'allais dire que les
chiffres existent malheureusement j'ai
les chiffres anglais en tête donc je
vais pas pouvoir répondre sur la forme
légale des chiffres en France mais si
vous voulez je peux revenir vers vous
pour vous donner des chiffres
merci beaucoup d'autres interventions
Jean-Pierre mega
excusez-moi j'ai plus de son voilà c'est
bon
oui le moi j'ai eu l'occasion
dans ma vie de
d'avoir et d'avoir à gérer des
prix de participation et d'intéressement
et
je vous assure que
il y avait une époque tout à l'heure il
parlait des années 75 où il y avait
beaucoup de primes individualisés et
dans les entreprises alors effectivement
des entreprises assez importantes où il
y avait l'intéressement et la
participation moi je trouvais que
c'était un outil de cohésion de
management le président l'a dit mais
aussi de cohésion dans l'entreprise
qu'elle soit petite ou grande parce que
on partage le résultat on est associé
aux résultats et je crois que dans les
petites entreprises il y a certainement
de la pédagogie à faire mais tout le
monde a le a le même objectif
le résultat est de résultats partagés
alors c'est vrai que il y a des
entreprises qui ont des résultats qui
sont extraordinaires d'autres qui en ont
qui sont malheureusement tout petits et
il y a par rapport à ça et pour laisser
salarié une grande inégalité parce que
quand il y a pas de résultats il
faudrait peut-être réfléchir aussi parce
que j'ai un qui font des super profits
on pourrait peut-être voir si il y a pas
une solution pour écrêter et pouvoir
répartir sur les autres mais en fait
c'est sujet qui ne figure pas dans la
loi c'est dommage mais je crois que
c'est vraiment ça peut être vraiment
même dans une une petite entreprise un
outil de management vous parliez de
management vertueux
demain juin vertueux et aussi de de
partage et qui est pas le patron qui
récupère tout le résultat et que les les
ouvriers mon Dieu ont que ce que ce
qu'on veut bien leur laisser au travers
de leur salaire et puis après le plan
d'épargne entreprise je pense que c'est
aussi quelque chose d'important pour les
salariés je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez parce que ça peut leur permettre
aussi dans la vie s'ils veulent faire
une acquisition etc d'utiliser
c'est cet argent qui n'aurait pas
certainement placé s'il avait touché
tous les mois et c'est aussi au niveau
de la de la RSE et au niveau social
quelque chose qui me paraît d'être
important et et qu'il faut vraiment
souligner
alors sur ces sujets là qui qui me
suggérer peut-être vraiment très très
brièvement parce que je ne peux que sans
jeux de mots a bondé dans dans votre
sens mais d'abord je crois effectivement
que l'épargne salariale est un
formidable outil de différenciation pour
ceux qui la pratiquent c'est encore plus
vrai donc dans les petites entreprises
puisqu'on voit que la couverture est
très fort dans les entreprises de plus
de 1000 salariés mais dans les petites
entreprises notamment confrontées à des
problématiques de recrutement et de
fidélisation de leurs collaborateurs on
voit que généralement ceux qui le font à
la fois entretiennent un meilleur climat
social en moyenne et une meilleure
fidélisation de leurs collaborateurs
vous parliez des dates j'ai retenu de
1975 et 2010 moi ce qui me frappe quand
je rencontre un certain nombre
d'entreprises c'est que ceux qui l'ont
mis en place il y a 10 15 20 ans l'ont
toujours 10 15 20 ans plus tard donc il
y a une vraie il y a un vrai engouement
pour ceux qui le pratiquent c'est à dire
qu'à un moment donné on n'est plus dans
la perception le frein dans ce qu'ils
pratiquent on est dans la perception du
frein dans ceux qui se posent la
question de savoir s'ils vont passer à
l'action donc ça c'est un premier point
sur le deuxième par rapport au plan
d'épargne entreprise ce que vous avez
dit est d'autant plus vrai qu'il y a
aussi des cas de déblocage qui sont
prévus par le législateur un peu plus de
d'une dizaine de cas maintenant alors je
vous cacherai pas que il y a le recto et
le Verseau de cette affaire le recto
c'est qu'effectivement c'est un bon
moyen notamment pour faire face à un
certain nombre je dirais de d'éléments
de nos cycles de vie à tous
on a on acquiert un bien immobilier on
va faire des travaux on a un changement
de situation personnelle et donc on peut
aller puiser dans le plan d'épargne il
faut faire attention peut-être d'être de
rester raisonnable aussi sur ces quatre
déblocages parce que ces cas de
déblocage qui viennent à se démultiplier
ça veut dire quoi bah ça veut dire que à
nouveau on retombe un peu dans le schéma
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure c'est à
dire que l'épargne salariale c'est plus
beaucoup de l'épargne gne et c'est
beaucoup de pouvoir d'achat très court
terme donc est-ce que les dispositifs de
partage de la valeur ça veut ça doit
être du pouvoir d'achat à court terme ou
du pouvoir d'achat moyen terme moi je
défends l'idée que de façon privilégiée
ça doit être du pouvoir d'achat à moyen
terme après avec un usage qui est celui
qu'on veut en faire et avec des
précautions sur la manière dont on en
parle mais en tout cas pour moi la
finalité de l'épargne salariale pardon
de le dire c'est une tautologie c'est de
faire de l'épargne pas du pouvoir
d'achat
merci point de vue sur ce sujet
peut-être oui je voulais juste revenir
sur ce le premier point que vous avez
fait qui ou bien évidemment je suis tout
à fait d'accord et c'était un peu ce que
j'essayais de faire passer comme message
dans ma présentation
en début c'est à dire que ces outils
d'intéressant de participation c'est
essentiellement des outils pour
permettre d'aligner les intérêts des
salariés et des employeurs donc c'est
vraiment un outil de gouvernance
d'entreprise un outil managérial vous
pouvez utiliser ce terme c'est et c'est
pour ça que j'essayais de finalement de
distinguer tous ces objectifs de
d'améliorer la gouvernance des
entreprises qui est un objectif tout à
fait louable pour les petites comme pour
les grandes entreprises des questions de
pouvoir d'achat qui à mon sens sont des
questions un peu différentes et où là la
principale partie enfin le principal
point de partage de la valeur j'étais
finalement vont être les salaires donc
voilà donc je ne peux que quatre accords
avec votre premier point
l'imposa quelques réflexions sur pouvoir
d'achat ou pas
sur
comment dire sur
cet outil effectivement ça ces outils ça
peut je suis entièrement d'accord ça
peut être un vrai outil de cohésion et
de management dans l'entreprise
je crois que ce qui manque vraiment
notamment dans les plus petites
structures et j'en ai déjà parlé c'est
la culture en fait avec ses produits
montrer le bénéfice que ça peut avoir
alors peut-être d'ailleurs que ça
devrait passer bien en amont c'est à
dire que quand on a des des jeunes qui
font des écoles de commerce de gestion
peut-être que ces outils devraient
systématiquement être présentés
en expliquant les bénéfices de chacun
notamment de l'intéressement et du plan
épargné entreprise le plan épargne
entreprise il a intéressant aussi
fortement notamment quand il y a un
abondement de l'entreprise et ça il faut
bien l'avoir en tête parce qu'il faut
aussi que l'entreprise puisse verser
l'amendement sinon clairement ça
ça fonctionnera pas
et enfin sur les quatre déblocages
effectivement on a une dizaine de cas
aujourd'hui existants l'ami d'ailleurs
avait proposé trois quatre déblocages
supplément supplémentaires qui
correspondent en fait aux gros enjeux de
la société actuellement qui sont
l'acquisition d'un véhicule propre
puisqu'on sait que pour beaucoup de
ménages notamment les ménages qui ont
moins de moyens
et bien comment vont-ils acquérir un
véhicule électrique
un des deuxièmes enfin le deuxième cas
des blocages c'était sur la rénovation
du logement principal qui soit en
location qui soit en locataire ou qui
soit propriétaire parce que là encore
c'est des coûts qui peuvent être très
lourds pour des ménages qui n'ont pas
forcément les moyens et puis et puis
dernier cas qui a été évoqué dans le
cadre de cette année c'est la
possibilité de débloquer pour des
proches aidants c'est à dire quand vous
avez des factures pour que la personne
reste à domicile alors tout ça ça reste
à déterminer peut-être plus précisément
dans le cadre de décret mais il nous
semblait intéressant aussi de coller les
quatre déblocage aux problématiques de
notre société de notre société actuelle
parce que l'épargne c'est très bien mais
il faut aussi pour que
l'économie tourne et pour répondre à la
problématique de nos salariés dans nos
entreprises
pouvoir mettre en place des solutions
qui répondent à tout ça
merci alors on va devoir conclure
peut-être dernier mot Martine liberté
oui peut-être merci président merci
beaucoup à vous toutes et tous
moi je pense qu'effectivement il y a ce
lien avec la RSE qui est vrai qui
indéniable au niveau de ce texte et
peut-être que alors que l'on disait
enfin alors qu'il n'était pas prévu que
la RSE soit obligatoire la mise en place
pour les TPE PME on voit bien qu'il y a
là un volet qui oblige finalement à
aller dans ce sens et c'est très bien
personnellement bon comme nous le
disions tout à l'heure
cet aspect d'intéressement et
est un moyen de gouvernance
effectivement et on retrouve bien là une
part de la de la RSE je suis je suis un
peu interpellée par la dernière partie
de ce texte qui est promouvoir une
épargne verte solidaire et responsable
quand on sait quels sont les difficultés
à s'assurer de ces de ces fonds enfin
que ces fonds soient vraiment verts et
on l'a vu lors de la RSE qu'est-ce que
cela vous appelle comme peut-être comme
remarque au niveau des entreprises
peut-être la CPME
ce qui avait été
effectivement demandé par certains et on
nous a dit que ça serait pas possible
c'était d'avoir un taux
d'épargne verte nettement supérieur à ce
qui est proposé d'ailleurs dans le texte
nous ce que le on est bien conscient au
niveau des entreprises de toute façon
qu'il faut aller vers ces engagements
verts et écologiques vous parliez de RSE
je crois qu'on a tous notre rôle à jouer
là on s'écarte un peu du débat mais nous
avons tous notre rôle à jouer dans la
transition écologique de notre pays et
les tpeme en sont bien conscients la
seule chose c'est qu'il y a toujours
cette notion de temporalité et
d'investissement pourquoi parce que les
investissements que nous devons faire
dans nos entreprises sont parfois très
lourds avec un retour sur investissement
ou en tout cas une capacité d'absorption
des charges des coûts liés à ces
investissements qui sont très difficiles
à prendre en charge pour les TPE PME
nous nous sommes très satisfaits qui est
une note un peu plus solidaire
responsable et verte en tout cas dans ce
projet de loi pour être tout à fait
honnête et transparent
merci un petit mot de conclusion chacun
si vous voulez
merci
je pense dans ma présentation voilà j'ai
été je pense effectivement qu'il y a des
sujets très intéressants qui sont
abordés qui mais en essayant bien de
reprendre ça dans un point de vue plus
global qui sont des sujets qui sont liés
à la gouvernance de l'entreprise et
beaucoup moins aux questions de partage
au niveau national et et de pouvoir
d'achat
merci super héros peut-être un mot un
mot très rapide alors pour pour dire
continuer évidemment vers la
simplification on l'a dit être attentif
à la question de l'articulation entre
les dispositifs je pense que c'est
souhaitable pour que encore une fois la
lisibilité et la cohérence l'emportent
et enfin un dernier point qu'on n'a pas
évoqué dans la pérennisation des
dispositifs c'est aussi la permanent la
permanence du portage au sein de l'État
de ce sujet il y a un engouement
politique pour ce sujet et c'est très
bien
quand c'est engouement politique une
fois les législations
retombées on va les périodes
législatives retombées
est-ce que comment est-ce qu'on s'assure
effectivement du portage du sujet qui
est un sujet
interministériel mais qui est
aujourd'hui porté par les grandes
administrations au ministère de
l'Économie des Finances au ministère du
Travail de l'autre je pense qu'il serait
souhaitable de réfléchir à un dispositif
de montage permanent au sein de l'État
et plutôt rattaché à Matignon et au
Premier ministre est-ce que ça doit
prendre la forme d'une délégation
interministérielle avec des moyens pas
forcément très important mais qui
permettrait de s'assurer à la fois
d'assurer la veille de tous les toutes
les améliorations législatives et
réglementaires qui restent à conduire la
mise en oeuvre et l'application des
textes réglementaires on sait que
parfois ça prend un peu de temps
faciliter les arbitrages entre les
ministères les plus concernés sur le
sujet animé de façon interministérielle
les débats avec les partenaires sociaux
les entreprises et les professionnels de
l'épargne salariale notamment dans une
optique d'accompagnement et puis
structurer développer la communication
autour des dispositifs de partage de la
valeur aujourd'hui
toute la communication est quand même
restée très loi pacte je pense qu'il y a
un travail d'actualisation à faire et
évidemment il faudra le faire une fois
que le projet de loi aura pu être adopté
de façon à ce que chacun comprenne de
façon
avec beaucoup de granularité les acquis
de la loi pacte les acquis de la loi zap
les acquis de la loi pouvoir d'achat les
acquis de Lagny et du présent projet de
loi je pense que c'est important
merci avant mon mot de conclusion de
deux annonces à faire mes chers
collègues le jeudi 1er juin nous
recevrons à 8h30 Carole Grandjean
ministre délégué chargé de
l'enseignement de la formation
professionnelle qui viendra pour
conclure le cycle d'audition de notre
mission formation compétences
attractivité dans le rapport sera
examiné le 29 juin et le jeudi 8 juin
nous auditionnons ensuite Olivia
Grégoire sur le thème de la
simplification dans le rapport de nos
collègues sera examiné le 15 juin
prochain voilà écoutez merci beaucoup
chacun d'entre vous d'avoir participé et
animer ce débat et un petit mot
peut-être encore
en fait je voulais juste j'ai pas pu
faire la conclusion donc si vous me
permettez juste très rapidement
nous c'est vrai on attend parce que ce
que l'on attend de ce texte et notamment
du passage au Sénat c'est de que que ce
projet de loi soit retranscrit le plus
fidèlement possible
vous savez sur cette notion de super
profit nous souhaitions que ça reste à
la main de l'employeur nous avons bien
entendu les difficultés que ça pouvait
engendrer notamment au niveau Conseil
constitutionnel sur le plan juridique
donc nous avons accepté de modifier
légèrement le contenu le contenu en tout
cas la rédaction et que l'on puisse
faire rentrer cette notion de
négociation en revanche nous souhaitons
bien sûr que que ça n'aille pas beaucoup
plus loin que ça pourquoi parce que
vous l'avez évoqué les entreprises de 11
à 50 étaient les plus visées
dans le cadre de cet accord un équilibre
a été trouvé et nous avons fait quand
même des efforts assez conséquents en ce
qui concerne notre typologie de
l'entreprise et nous souhaiterions que
cet équilibre soit conservé
lors de manières dans la retranscription
pardon législative merci beaucoup en
tous les cas
merci encore à chacun d'entre vous
d'avoir participé à ce débat et je vous
souhaite une bonne fin de journée merci
encore
bonne fin de journée au revoir à tous